hello my name is ya'muru god I'm the CEO
of all from mathcore developers of
system muddler I will be presenting a
vault from system model for and what has
been you during the last year okay thank
you very much so as Phil said I hope you
enjoyed the dinner and additive public
cloud and I will be introducing the new
system alert for SS Phil said I did a
presentation last year on what was
coming up with system all over for so
some of it will be a repetition but I
will take it with new examples other
things will be new because I didn't
present everything and furthermore who
have released more material during the
year and basically as some of you will
not be that familiar with system agra
we'll start with presenting system or as
self with a very basic example then I
will go into what was new with let's see
my cursor there what's new in system
mother for where we were working on on
the user interface documentation I will
just quickly pass that then then go into
new built-in libraries connectivity and
deployment and show some deeper
integration with mathematica because
that's one of the keys with system over
the ability to connect it to Mathematica
and do some interesting design and
analysis using Mathematica during the
year we also introduced the library
store where you can have additional
functionality to add it to system
modelers i will present that briefly
also and then in I think februari might
be march we had system other 4.1
released which had a few extra
functionality including combining system
reliability with the system simulation
functionality that it already had and at
the end i will i will show a bit of how
you can learn more so let's get started
by a system modeler and what what is for
and so many of you have seen this slide
before for some it might be new is kind
of trying to illustrate which kind
systems do you want to model with a
something called system modular well
it's any system that is dynamic which is
changing over time it could be an
aircraft or an excavator robot the human
body or well this thing here so it can
be a variety of things the important
thing is that it can be described in
differential algebraic equations but as
a juicer you don't tend to work with the
differential algebraic equations you
will use with a drag-and-drop
environment with icons rather than
having to focus on the maths you can
focus on the on the physics on the
concepts pull that together and do
simulations if you like you can go into
the equations and study those too but
let's illustrate this with a very like a
very basic example how many here have
wondered what the squirrel can do with
the machine gun jetpack well so late
typically I start with a DC motor as the
introductory example but I thought that
was not as fun as investigating what
will happen if a squirrel would he have
a machine gun and try to use that to
propel himself up in the air some of you
might have seen this as a blog already
whereas eight XKCD but still I think
it's a very good illustration of how to
use sister muddler so what I do from
Mathematica here sister motor runs
standalone for Mathematica but I can
also run it from within Mathematica so
we'll need to load load sister mother
into mathematica and then I will open
this model in system over here we have
it so here you can see we have the Vinci
in equations what we have we have a
model for a squirrel for the machine gun
some position sensor and send a crash
detector and this is done with
plug-and-play of mostly ready-made
components from the library so if I
click into the square all the squirrel
doesn't exist of course in our set of
libraries that's like the model of the
squirrel is really simplistic let's open
it this way instead
it's a yes the mass corresponding to the
mass of the other squirrel and the
gravitational force acting on it so it's
a very simple square can't really do
anything but i guess not having the
brain model of the squirrel doesn't make
too much difference is kind of not that
intelligent anyway so in the same way we
have the machine gun and we have the
crash detector components basis drag and
drop and once once everyone in ones and
then you don't have ready-made
components i can drag and drop form then
you make some some equations but let's
not go into that instead well let's do a
simulation from system in system / first
of this so i click simulate this is
converted to a C code actually and I can
simulate and see the position sensor to
see with one gun shooting how high will
I fly so we'll find like nine
centimeters something like that what
would one bullet I can then see okay
let's say that we have more bullets what
will happen then so let's go into the
gun and say that it has let's say ninety
five bullets and then it will shoot the
bullets in sequence and we can see here
that it will continue to propel at some
point in time it starts to follow and
then it happens at 70 meters so I guess
it's a pretty decent fall and the reason
why is falling is of course because it
runs out of runs out of ammunition so I
can actually look at that I guess let's
go into the gun and I assume there is
something showing Wow let's keep that
somewhere there there there is a
variable for for for the number of
bullish shop anyway that is how you have
your model and you seem light in system
modeler and that could be the square
what could be a DC motor or or a vehicle
or something
like a human body to see the metabolism
example like that but once you have a
model you can look at what would happen
if the human being would try to do this
and then we make a platform of a lot of
machine guns and we see how high can we
actually propel this so we use now
parameters that correspond to to an ache
or ak-47 I guess I'm not that good at at
machine guns I must admit I'm a Swede we
we shoot Alex not and not with machine
guns so I have all the like the bullet
mass the muscle velocity and so on so
and those are yes setting as parameters
to the very same model because it's just
the very same behavior just more mass
and more guns more bullets and then I
can simulate this from within mathematic
at this time and I went pretty quickly
it ran a few simulations in parallel oh
I already evaluated is let's do that
again so you can see that so we can see
that depending on the number of bullets
I have the behavior will be quite
different and this is why you have a
modeling tool because even if this was
kind of a toy example it actually saw
something who would have imagined this
behavior for instance that you would be
flying up and then after a while you
will be losing height before you start
to fly upwards again and then drop down
we for sure thought it was a bug in our
model first before we realize the real
physics behind it which is really simple
and some of you might already have
realized what it is I won't tell it but
you can read it on the blog or then
download the model and play around
yourself to see why is this but this is
why you have models to see something
that is kind of unexpected for you and
try to understand why is this going on
how can I use this to improve the
performance of my model how can propel
the myself over the Statue of Liberty
how high can I actually fly which is the
number of guns that is ideal to fly as
high as possible
in fact I can in theory hundred fifty
five meters if I have the right num
number of guns with the right right
ammunition and I guess it there are some
limitations to this in balancing and so
on so that is system over what it's all
about and now over to system order four
and one of the things that I want should
show that much but we work a lot on the
only user interface especially on the
documentation side to make it as
accessible as possible adding videos
explaining how to use it having a lot of
cross-linking yes that's the mathematica
help were you if you're going into one
component or one function their cross
links two examples where that is used
and there is also inside the tool itself
a complete book about the modelica
language which is used for the models in
sister modular that you can read and
with examples to understand how to how
to do your texts your modeling in with
full advantage taking full advantage of
it okay so it's a lot about having built
in libraries that that so you can drag
and drop as many systems as possible
without having to do any coding of
yourself so with sister mother for we
added a digital library we added
functionality the rotational and
translational mechanical library and
some cosa stationary and fundamental
wave and you kind of see which type of
of systems you're supposed to model with
with the different libraries so the
rotational and translational I breasts
already existed and and the important
thing is that you can connect all these
together so when you build the entire
system it's not only the mechanical part
only the electrical part is all those
together and that's what's interesting
with a new rotational and translational
functionality which I will use an
example of so
let's import that model to sister
muddler and open it so this let's zoom
in a bit like that this is a mechanical
models as many of you kind of can see
but we has connection here to heat ports
so we added the ability to to model the
heat losses in mechanical systems and in
this is of course very important if you
are trying to understand efficiency of
your system so once you have this model
where you have let's say a clutch here
and the clutch has some heat loss where
you have modeled let's say the
surrounding temperature or whatever that
you need in order to get that you can
see study things like the generated heat
so I'll simulate this from within I can
simulate that in system over or from
within Mathematica so I do simulation
with a different and then plot this dry
train hopefully this works I changed the
entire presentation kind of last night
so I hope everything will are but here
we can see over time for an experiment
here the heat loss plotted over time and
we can see there are some some points we
are losing a lot of energy but we're
always losing some and then we can try
to understand when are we losing energy
when are we not losing energy basically
it's when the clutches are are attaching
and we'll have slide sliding motion in
the in the clutches where we have the
most heat loss and so on but we can use
this of course to optimize the operation
and minimize the heat loss which is
typically something that you would like
but of course there are other design
constraints that might be more important
in some cases and then you have to
consider those too you can also do some
things like looking at what what will
have it was do we have for each
component in the system and something
going on here hopefully it gives me
something soon
and so in this example we'll use
Mathematica to kind of crunch all all
variables that has anything to do with
heat loss so we will look our heat flow
we're looking for every variable that
has heat flow in it and then we try to
to do a pie chart which for some reason
won't come up here perhaps i'll i'll
skip that yeah let's let's skip that
I'll go back to that later another
important addition and this is really
important is once you have a model you
want to use in as many ways as possible
many many times that is by connecting it
to other software's or other hardware's
and this is such an important aspect so
I won't show it here instead I will have
a presentation later today focus
completely on on this but basically I
was planning to open the model where I
will show for instance how to run this
guy and control it from a model so we
will have the control system developed
in system order and run this model where
we will be trying to balance this bowl
here and this this zoom is thanks to a
new library called model plug which is
free additional library and with that
you can create your own experiments like
that easily it could be this one you
will see several other types of
experiments that you could be doing for
your lab or for home use as in this case
it was one of our employees that does
all kinds of things we have a lot of
kids working at math girl they look all
but there are apparently kids
okay so a system reliability I saw what
I was modeling was how something was
actually working when it's working you
can also model things like which I have
presented before how is something how
would something behave if you have some
error for instance this one that the
that comes from an old old blog where we
were testing the flap systems of a
Cessna conquest well we have this model
here where we have a pilot we have an
easy you flap system the the hydraulic
power and the landing gear and the power
plants so all of those are are described
in similar way to the square oh yes with
slightly different components actually
in the case of other flaps is a lot of
the same components as for the squirrel
because it's masses and movements and so
on but anyways you have this and and
then the question was what happened if
we for instance had a short circuit
circuit in in the system and we could
see that there are scenarios where you
have that and I hope that you can see
this and if we look at the middle plot
here what does is showing is the blue
that the red line is showing what the
product tries to do how he tries to
change the position of the flaps to
control the aircraft the blue is showing
what's actually happening so we can see
that that in the beginning he's changing
the angle of flap and then when he tries
to switch it back basically it's taking
off and once it's taken off he wants to
have the flaps in neutral position 0
degrees but that doesn't happen doesn't
really matter that much because it's
just losing some some flying more
inefficiently but when he wants to land
it's more important to be able to to get
him in a proper angle to decrease speed
but that isn't happening either and this
is because of an elec
failure so you can model these types of
failures and see what would happen if i
have this failure what kind of scenarios
can happen what kind of sensors would I
need to detect this this type of error
and then Saul find things that you have
been able to do for a long time in
system otter but what you can do with 41
is to use the really nice functionality
of reliability that Mathematica has oh
that's right I and so let's open a model
with that thought I had a link for that
cruise control cruising
I actually have it here yes very good so
so here's the system again in system of
learning I will guess so as I said it
looks if I go into the flaps it will
kind of look similar to what we saw in
the squirrel yes more components and
some different we have we have some
hydraulic system some mechanical system
and so on but what what matters is that
we have now a reliability tab here so
the reliability tab you can set
distributions to any component any
system and describe for instance in this
case every liability distribution you
can pick for any of the distributions
available in Mathematica like sensor
distribution reliability distribution
and so on and then said some
functionality how does this depend on
the different subsystems in this case
we're saying it it has the hydraulic
power it's hard to read I guess from
from the back by the hydraulic power and
the flaps how to work for this folder to
work otherwise the system fails then of
course the question is how does the the
flaps what's required for the flaps work
so let's open that class and we can see
that in this case we have a royal bit
the distribution with a long expression
of all the pipes and all the different
components here and if we go into a
single pipe that has a failure
distribution so in the class of the park
will have this failure distribution and
once we kind of drag and drop it onto to
our system and connect it every one of
them will have this failure distribution
so we don't have to rewrite this for
every single pipe is it's done once and
then of course I can change it if I like
24 individual pipe might have a
different behavior then I can can change
that description but this means i have
the reliability of the system together
with the possibility of actually
simulating what will happen if it fails
so let's look at at what we would do
with this reliability in the case of the
pipe we would have three different fault
modes which is it's leaking
it's a restricted flow or it's
completely blocked that's basically the
three four modes that have been modeled
in this case and likewise the electrical
system will have other the type of the
errors models and then we can do things
like simulating I guess something happen
well simulating the entire the
reliability of the different subsystems
so we can see here get the reliability
of the flap system in blue which is
quite reliable the hydraulic power
system is less reliable and the full
system of course less reliable than
those together because both of them have
to work so in this way we can realize
that the hydraulic power system seems to
be in more need of improvements than the
flap system but we can now use the other
function on Mathematica for instance no
it's ma'am for instance plotting there
are a bunch of different measures in
Mathematica for the importance of all
the different failures or the effects so
for instance the structural importance
and then we can see for for the
individual pipes which is the most
important failure and we can see here
that that the hub actually leads to the
blocked switch and the restrictive
switch have a very similar behavior in
in importance while the leaks which has
less importance so based on this we can
know which which of the folds are from a
reliability perspective most important
for us but then of course you want to do
the simulation to see which has the
worst effect because if the effect is
not that that the that dangerous then we
might even if it's very likely we might
not really care but if it's a great
danger to it then we will care anyways
so the possibility to combine these two
worlds together reliability with
functionality is really important and
something that is unique
sister modeller so as i mentioned i can
actually show that for those of you that
don't know the language behind the
scenes so here we have the diagram
behind the scenes there is a more
delicate language which looks like this
it's basically basically like any
programming language but it's
specifically designed for for for
complex systems and engineer resistance
biological systems and so on so it's not
really that that hard to learn but still
you might not want to do that in many
cases perhaps you are a vivid
Mathematica Wolfram language programmer
then perhaps you want to do it in the
Wolfram language instead and not have to
care about more Elega then you can do
that from for version 4 so you can
create models from equations like for
instance in this case I create a model
called new model one and then in new
model 2 and so on so if i create new
model one here we can see it says ok we
took this state space equation and it
stores in new model one so if i go to
system modeler now let's let's do like
this I can see among my used classes I
have this new model one here and I can
drag and drop that and connect that into
the rest of my system yes as any other
component modelica i can then go in of
course in a look at what what happened
how is this constructed and in the
modelica world this actually is a very
simple model where we are inheriting
from a state space model and setting the
parameters that we gave it from
Mathematica but we don't need to know
that it just happens for us that could
be a transfer model or it could be
equation so so let's take a very simple
equation of equations like that one and
then create the model and we say in this
case let's call it add block and it will
inherit from blocks interfaces
single-input single-output so in this
case you know not to need to know a
little bit
about what's available in Metallica and
then you can add functionalized that is
all rebel there inherit that into your
model and say add these equations to
that model and make it a function of
time so I model that and yet again now
if I open the add block I can go into
that and see that in this case is in
harwich something else and it has the
equation to it and this could be a very
complicated expression sometimes or as
in this case very simplistic so one of
the reasons to use it is that your are
already used to mathematical from
language you want to keep their but
there's other reasons too sometimes you
want to programmatically create a set or
like a like a big settle or models
different for instance for the full full
modes rather than having to connect all
the different types of four combinations
of all modes or whatever you have you
have model it you can programmatically
let Mathematica by programming that have
it create a set or models and then you
don't have to do all that abuse like a
few lines of code in mathematic I mean
will it will populate the entire set of
models for you but you can also from
Mathematica well this relates more to
what I said you can connect components
together so you can say i want this type
of class using from from system order
set their list of components called r l
AC g most of you kind of understand
which type of system that is and then we
say connect this using rules so g dot p
connect to ACN and so on so i can
programmatically say how to connect
something in using double gem connect
components so i'll do that and it's
where it's fine acceptable for one thing
and you will see that soon it the
diagram is kind of not that good-looking
but it's easy to fix because you have it
in system order now and you can can try
to rearrange oh sorry
and you can try to rearrange stuff like
moving around and let's do this reset
connection line move around and try to
see how should this be arranged to look
good and then you have your system there
ok so let's see how I'm on time yeah
pretty good so then during the year one
of the things we launched for system all
for was this library store and the idea
what the library store is to add
functionality that is quite specific for
a domain that not everybody would be
kind of interested in all ways sometimes
very specialized but very advanced like
the smart cooling library which the guys
from AIT which back there have been
developing this is available as a paid
library from our library store yes as a
hydraulic library where you can add that
functionality to your system other
models by buying us those but there are
also some free libraries available like
the model plug which I will be shown
show you later on where you can do this
kind of thing and ideas that we will be
adding libraries as we go by so in
between releases you can see added
functionality and that is not only by us
as I said smart cooling is developed by
AIT and sister dynamics is also a
third-party library plain planar
mechanics at third party library model
plug happened to be modeled by developed
at home by the guy that that wanted to
play and so in that way there's an
infrastructure now for producers to add
functionality to to sister modular by
developing their own library and they
can distribute either for free through
our library store or as a paid library
yeah
sorry okay so I guess the question is if
you can use all the Model X so there is
a lot of modelica libraries out there in
principle the answer is yes but the real
answer i have to admit is no because
there are many modelica libraries that
are not complying completed modelica
they have for instance tiny molar
specific code still so they have some
cleanup of doing and many are outdated
and those like all versions that were
not supporting those who work is there
are some some restrictions that but in
principle yes you can kind of use others
and yeah well that's one of the reasons
why we're doing this because that's a
very common questions which kind of use
which I can I not use and it's very hard
to say because those libraries are
developed often by a PhD student and
once the PhD student goes somewhere else
the library kind of vanishes isn't it is
basically discontinued but with anyone
saying is discontinued so there's no
future no development done so when
modelica upgrades there's no upgrade to
that and then it doesn't work with it
and so on so it's it's a kind of comp so
this is one of the main reasons why we
create this in order to two piece by
piece go curating the libraries and make
sure that they're fully tested with
system order that we can guarantee not
only that are working but also that the
documentation is actually good the
examples are available are good so we
have quality measures on what you have
to provide in the library in order to be
able to submit it to our library store
and then also it has some other
functionality where the actual comes
packed where you only you get it you
double-click it installs and everything
is automatically and you can add like de
scripting videos documentation and so on
in a very nice format so there are
several reasons for this story
yes as long as it's modelica true
modelica ademola used to have because
dan Mohler came from a language called
I'm Allah and they have some dynamo
artifacts in many of the let's say die
mullah models so depending on that okay
and I won't really talk too much about
the different libraries but let's let me
has to show the hydraulic library
quickly from the library store so in the
library store you will see the libraries
describe the price or whether there are
are free you can request a trial you and
in this case you can see it's 645 pounds
if you're based in Sweden you can change
to whichever country you want to see the
price for and then you will see the key
features but you will also have examples
for how to use it where is it applicable
so for instance I could go go into two
motors and valves and see that example
and then I can see a description of
modern valves how can how can use that
what kind of all the analysis can you do
on that and so on so here you can can
learn about the different libraries and
get an idea if this is something for you
and if it is you can request a trial or
buy it directly
so that that is a very quick summary of
what's new in 41 or in 4 and 4 1 as i
said i will show more on connectivity
part later on later today at this very
same room i think at 1445 but i will
also like to show some other resources i
just showed one example but actually
there are a bunch of different examples
not all of you are from from the field
of modeling squirrels or or or aircrafts
perhaps you are more interested in other
applications then you might want to see
examples from your specific field then
you can go to the industry examples and
you will see kind of the different
fields whether it's let's say meal
simulation which is quite different from
what we have done now you can go in and
see several different examples from from
life science you will see the example in
some cases I think this one for instance
insulin signaling the model is
downloadable so you own you get a
description of the model but it can also
download it to run it with the trial had
already open it before I see and when I
open it I can see here is a for instance
in a notebook with a description of how
to run this and some experiments and so
on that you can do whatever you like
with so you can use that if you want to
have it to deploy it on the class to do
a some kind of example you can do that
if you just for learning yourself they
can do that and you can modify it in
whichever way you you like so this is a
great resource in order to understand
how it applies to your domain ok we have
we were pretty bad at producing blogs
before this year we have added quite a
lot so these are the blog's that have
come up for system out during the last
year since the last conference and in
general I would say these are
we have we have the square all their ass
as i said but in general there are more
serious kind where it's a real-life
topic that that matters for some domain
like let's say this one here can astra
zeneca count on your liver that one is
showing how astrazeneca is using system
over in order to together with an MRI
scan analyze your liver so rather than
nowadays to analyze deliver you have to
take a biopsy and that is a pretty
intrusive and it has a lot of its costs
and complications and it takes several
weeks before you you're up and running
in full shape again but here instead
they put you into mrs MRI scan do image
processing in mathematica use that
images to to correlate to models
simulate and understand the how the
condition the health condition of your
liver so in that way you can you can you
can diagnose the liver without having an
intrusive biopsy which is pretty cool i
would say for more technical questions i
think this is general for for the entire
world from communities of all time
community was launched i I don't know
exactly anyone knows when was well from
communities like two years ago something
like that yet we take that after what
she is soon yeah so I guess to wrap up
with a full from community in there now
so the Voltron community has a lot of
different for different forums for
instance for system over so i recommend
this for anyone that is trying out and
have have questions for this specific
area and we are both the community
themselves and we at the team are pretty
eager to answer the things that comes
into the community so that's a very very
good way to get your your questions
answered when it comes to technical
questions while trying out the software
it might be how do i model this how do i
model
that to have an idea for that I tried
this model I don't get it to work you
publish that model and then somebody
would come out there and help you and
that goes for entire mathematic I think
it's a very good resource that more
people should use in general for the
bold front products and and then I'll
say later today I will have another
presentation and with that I wrap up and
thank you and take some questions thank
you